TOO POLITICALLY DIFFICULT TO
MAKE THEM LEAVE.
THAT'S WHAT WE THINK.
DISAGREE WITH IT?
YOU ARE ALWAYS WELCOME ON THE
SHOW.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST IN THE SUBJECT OF MANY
ATTACKS ON MINE SINCE HIS LAST
APPEARANCE ON THE SHOW,
INCLUDING A TAKE ON JOY READS
SHOW OVER THE WEEKEND SO WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD INVITE HIM BACK
AND ASKING FOR A RESPONSE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, MARK?
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
FASCINATED TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR
GREAT GRANDFATHER FROM
SWITZERLAND IN 1860.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME -- ONE OF
THE THINGS I LIKE ABOUT YOU,
TUCKER, ONE OF THE FEW THINGS IS
THAT WHEN YOU DISCUSS
IMMIGRATION, YOU DON'T GO ON
ABOUT YOUR GREAT-GRANDFATHER AND
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THAT
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE SAY PEOPLE
ATTACK IMMIGRATION, MY
GREAT-GRANDMOTHER GOT OFF THE
BOAT AT ELLIS ISLAND IN 1979 AND
SIX WEEKS LATER SHE WAS THE
THIRD ORPHAN ON THE RIGHT AND
THE BROADWAY PRODUCTION OF NA
DREAM RIGHT THERE.
THEY EITHER DO THAT, THEY EITHER
DO THAT, OR THEY SAY WELL, YOU
KNOW, I'VE GOT A VENEZUELAN POOL
BOY AND HE IS THE HARDEST
ONE, BECAUSE YOU ARE ONE OF THE
FEW PEOPLE WHO DOESN'T DISCUSS
IT IN TERMS OF YOUR
GREAT-GRANDFATHER, MSNBC HAS
HIRED SOMEBODY TO FIND OUT WHO
YOUR GREAT-GRANDFATHER IS AND
HANG HIM AROUND YOUR NECK.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, THIS IS
COMPLETELY PREPOSTEROUS.
THERE WERE LOTS OF THINGS WE
RAILROAD, OXEN AND ODDLY ENOUGH,
A HUNDRED AND 60 YEARS LATER WE
NEED LESS OF ALL THOSE THINGS,
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING IS HOW THERE'S NO
REAL RESPONSE OTHER THAN TO THE
PERSONAL.
I KNOW THE TEMPTATION WHEN YOU
GET UPSET ABOUT SOMETHING TO TRY
AND HANG IT ON A PERSONAL HANG
UPS OR HIS PERSONALITY OR
BACKGROUND OR WHATEVER, BUT YOU
TRY TO PULL BACK AND ASK WHAT
PRINCIPLES ARE AT STAKE HERE AND
ASK OBVIOUS QUESTIONS LIKE HOW
DOES THIS HELP THE AMERICANS
ALREADY HERE?
I CANNOT GET -- ARE NOT JUST
SAYING THIS.
EVERY NIGHT, I CANNOT GET A REAL
ANSWER FOR THAT FROM ANYBODY,
EVER.
NOT ONE.
>> IT IS THIS RESISTANCE IN
PUBLIC POLICY.
HAD SOMETHING SIMILAR AFTER I
WAS ON YOUR SHOW LAST WEEK.
POINTING OUT THAT I'M CANADIAN.
IT WAS THE FIRST I'D HEARD OF
IT.
THE FACT IS, IT'S PUBLIC POLICY.
A TRAGEDY FOR THE SWEDES WHO
WILL BE AN ETHNIC MINORITY IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY BY MIDCENTURY.
I GO TO MULLEN BEAK AND MY
MOTHER'S COUNTRY OF BELGIUM AND
HOUSE GENEALOGIST A BIT OF TIME,
I HAPPEN TO BE AN IRISH
YEAR.
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS, THERE
IN OUR LIFETIME.
THERE IS VERY LITTLE DIFFERENCE
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS BETWEEN
FRANCOPHONE QUEBEC, A HALF-HOUR
NORTH OF ME HERE IN NEW ENGLAND
MAJORITY OF FRANCOPHONE QUEBEC
VOTED THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
PUTTING ASIDE RACE, SMALL GROUP
DIFFERENCES CAN HAVE HUGE
CONSEQUENCES, AND THAT'S WHY I
COME BACK TO A POINT I MAKE A
LOT ON YOUR SHOW, THAT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
ESTABLISHED WITH JOY READ, IT'S
NOT THAT YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT
THE SUBJECT, IT'S JUST THAT AS
JOY SEES IT, ONLY CERTAIN PEOPLE
CAN TALK ABOUT IT.
IF SHE CAN SAY THE DEMOCRATS
SHOULD GIVE UP ON WHITE RURAL
VOTERS AND JUST FOCUS ON BLACK
VOTERS.
DEMOCRAT CAN SAY ON ELECTION
NIGHT 2012 THAT THIS IS ABOUT
THE BROWNING OF AMERICA.
BOB ON ELECTION NIGHT, ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT, CAN TALK ABOUT THE
WHITE VOTE.
WHAT JOY AND COWAS SAYING, THEY
>> Tucker: I WOULD RATHER NOT
PLAY BY THOSE RULES, AND NEITHER
CAN YOU.
>> IT'S NOT IN GOOD FAITH, WHICH